permettre une meilleure fluidité de la
circulation sur la route départementale
61 et 62 c'est l'objectif du chantier
qui a débuté sur cet axe situé à
proximité du nouveau quartier de
beauséjour
ici le trafic augmente de 100 % chaque
année ce sont en effet treize mille
véhicules pour la rd 62 et 2000 pour la
rd61 ce nouveau rond-point facilitera la
circulation difficile que moi mais
également d'ici quelques années puisque
l image de beauséjour d'autres quartiers
véritable ville dans la ville devrait
voir le jour sur les hauteurs de santi
marie permettre effectivement aux
usagers de pouvoir avoir une fluidité
quotidienne je parlerai même pas d'un
besoin je parlerai d'une nécessité
puisque encore une fois nous sommes sur
une zone qui était quand même réputée
dangereuse où il y avait quand même des
risques d'accident permanent et je crois
qu'il était très important de pouvoir
assurer une meilleure connexion entre la
rd 61 et 62 compte tenu de ses nouveaux
quartiers naissance aux saintes maries
savoir la zac beauséjour qui est à
proximité
la zac beauséjour c'est quasiment huit
mille habitants qui viendront
s'installer dans les années à venir et
je crois qu'il était plus que nécessaire
de sécuriser cette portion de route pour
permettre tout à chacun à la fois des
délais d'attentes qu'ils soient réduits
aux heures de pointe des délais de
circulation a diminué mais également une
meilleure sécurisation du trafic en
général avec sept cent mille euros
d'investissement ce chantier le plus
gros chantier des routes concernant le
département pour l'année 2016 cinq mois
sur nécessaire pour faire sortir le
rond-point de terre cette phase de
travaux qui devraient permettre de ne
pas trop gêner la circulation
première phase ça va être la préparation
des deux oreilles
côté mer qui vont nous permettre à près
de basculer la circulation sur ces deux
parties
l'allemand réalisé ensuite tu auras le
quart sud est qui sera réalisé troisième
grande phase le cas opposé
et pour terminer pour la quatrième
grande fan ça va être la pause des îlots
centraux et des enrobés finaux un
investissement qui va au delà d'un
simple rond point puisque le département
engager des études de faisabilité des
routes mais également de l'eau deux
éléments essentiels pour le
développement des eaux de l'est une
solution pour des milliers de personnes
qui ne pourront pas tous habités sur la
cote
tout en préservant la richesse des
terres agricoles de l'est nous sommes à
250 mètres de hauteur ici nous sommes
probablement les études vont le
confirmer à la porte d'entrée de cette
route néo de l'est et j'espère que dans
les 10 15 ans qui viennent il y ait des
petits beauséjour qui se forment dans
les eaux de l'est également
il faut reconquérir ses terres qu'ils
sont inoccupés aujourd'hui et nous à ce
rééquilibrage est positif pour
l'ensemble de l'île
le développement harmonieux permettra de
préserver la zone littorale
aujourd'hui nous avons des terres à fort
potentiel agricole qui sont menacées par
l'urbanisation la collectivité les élus
de la majorité ont doublé les
investissements concernant les routes
départementales en 2016 ce sont 20
millions qui seront réinjectés dans
l'entretien la construction de nouveaux
axes sur tout le territoire